good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Wednesday hope
everybody's having a gorgeous hump day
it is moving day for me it is chaos in
my life hey JX how you doing I'm ding
good I'm
excited virtually excited for moving day
for law no like like everything is wrong
you know what I mean like everything is
wrong how so just everything like I'm
Vlogging vlogging this experience and
everyone will hear about it but just
like I I couldn't even sleep last night
I'm so tired I was so excited woke up in
the middle of the night realized I
forgot to clean out my freezer scrub in
the freezer scrub in the freezer get
back in bed can't sleep Ben snoring away
like I was just so excited and now the
fact that I couldn't sleep like put me
in a bad mood oh goodness oh goodness me
yeah okay and I absolutely need to take
my rage out on someone it won't be you
it will be bad okay that's fair and I
will and Ben just got to the new place
Ben just got to the new place sending me
pictures there's literally like huge
marks in the floor that's frustrating
what is that I don't know rug no it's
like big scratches but it's it's in an
area that I wasn't putting a rug and why
should I have to put a rug down because
somebody else is an animal you know I do
know t t is lit and then I was feeling
enraged this morning I was feeling
enraged this morning and I was like oh
I'm definitely getting my period because
this is just like a foul [__] mood
that I'm in and I realized in my little
app I didn't um mark down my last period
and thank God I talk about it so much on
the toast can anybody let me know when
my last period was I don't think that
was a month ago yeah no but I think I'm
coming up when we posted that clip of
how are you
doing yes let's find out what day that
was and we'll do the math from there
yeah I I almost never forget to put my
cycle in my little p Tracker app which
is such a fabulous app you know we might
be almost a month that's what I'm saying
like this sort of nasty mood is so
hormonal it's
menstrual okay well hopefully you have
something to pin it on the toast is here
to booy you as we always do and we're
going to try to lift up tury Spirits no
and this is what's so like I out turdi
the tury like God forbid I just don't
like I take the day off like I shouldn't
even be here right now I should be
moving but I'm so toxic in my like work
environment you know like we can't miss
a show but what would you be doing
really there it's in it's in roadway
hands now you have to sit back honestly
one time roadway moved me I got a
pedicure there's That's how little there
was for me to do on the day of the
actual move I'm so
controlling you have to let go and let
roadway lard I don't think I can what's
going to happen like why so stressed the
uh the clip I need to know where my
period was no I mean I can go back yeah
I'm stressed I'm really stressed but
like what's going to why why is this
move making you so stressed like it's
just moving things from one place to
another it's not like you know me check
I don't like change my God you made me
do this and it's your fault I thought
given how excited you were about the
move that we were you going to usurp
tury's change ofers ways but no my
period was on October 4th what day is it
no you're not there yet sis not even
close but let me update my app I hate
not having all my cycle information in
in one October
4th I remember now oh I
remember okay I'm adding my period thank
you everyone for your patience I have
seven days left so you're right this
might not be linked I don't know but the
week before your period's always like
kind of the craziest week yeah life is
either like you know oh I'm getting my
period oh I'm having my period oh I just
finished my period yeah I'm just sick of
it I'm sick of it get pregnant Womanhood
no shut up shut up you guys pray for me
today I'm going to do my best to
navigate turd through these stressful
Waters but I don't know she's lit up I
am lit up you just got lit up you know
when you were like actually there's an
episode of second the sex in the city
that really is so perfect it's like New
York City is the perfect place to be
angry you can walk in the street and
like give people dirty looks like shove
people like it's really just and people
match that energy when I I walked like
with rage in my legs like I looked like
a psycho yeah the only thing is though
like you can't scream in the city like I
really feel like people are always
screaming oh if you want to be crazy and
like you know cause a scene but like you
can't just like let out a scream yeah I
guess like you could go into your
backyard and like let out a scream if
you lived in the suburbs even though
like your neighbors might hear you a
scream in the suburbs would like your
neighbors would call the police if you
were in your apartment in New York and
you screamed your neighbors would call
hopefully yeah but you could scream on
the street in New York it's it's very
casual no you can't not unless you want
to be a crazy person yeah and nobody
like crazy people just scream and
everybody just ignores them and they
move on with their days yeah but that's
not who you want to be sometimes you
just need to let out a screen without
like alarming anyone it's just for you
okay but where can you really do that
you can't do that in the suburbs you
could do it on a farm you could do it on
a farm for sure like in the mountains a
ranch
yeah Farm life has its
perks I think you need to let out a
scream not here also we posted a clip on
Instagram yesterday about Sweeping in
public bathrooms and I just wanted to
say I was not alone no it was like
50/50 yeah people knew what I was
talking about like wiping down the
counter with a paper towel and then also
like somebody else said something and I
do this too like pushing the paper
towels down in the bin you know yeah I
um it was nice to know I wasn't alone
that should bring you comfort as you
forge through this day as I Forge
through this mood as we all Forge
through the mood Len here's the thing
we're going to get through the toast and
skate it's really I'm really not in
control I don't have good control on my
moods like if I'm in a mood I have to
like
I can people get out of bad moods I
don't know about get out of them but
compartmentalize them for a second and
that also just helps you get out of it
assuming it's kind of a benign bad mood
no I'm like unable to control my moods
like they just control me and I think
you know I wake up every day and I'm a
delight on the show like literally
nobody's ever been nicer or more genuine
than me and today is just uh T's having
an off day okay um so I will I'll take
the lead here I'll Usher us through this
episode which is going to be a great one
because we have five really varied and
interesting stories we are not doing
deer toasters today due to the fact that
tury is moving and she needs her time
back so we'll do it later this week no
big deal we will help you later this
week and B deal it's no big deal I just
like you know it's like our show like
why not be a little flexible it's so
true sometimes I forget that we're
business owners no that you're we're the
boss who do you think is the
boss
us it depends on the topic at hand yeah
you know like when it comes to like show
running I would say you yeah when it
comes to business running like I would
say me yeah that's why we're such a
great team it's so true like was that a
weird question to ask no and what's even
greater is like we know our roles and we
also both know that that's how it is
like I S like I just said something you
were like oh no I don't feel that way
yeah no like if you were to ask me
something about the show like what I say
goes and you like you you listen to that
and if I ask you something about like
merch or like any other like back end of
the business like you have the final
word right right so that's just like
true partnership you guys yeah that's us
partners that's us partners partners
partners Brock
Partners well I think we should get into
the stories to take your mind off of
things I don't want to ask you continue
to ask you how you're doing to fester in
this w you know yeah it's like a good
day I'm just it's going to be a great
night listen Claude picture this no
tomorrow will be a great night cuz
you're going to unpack
tonight no I'm G to unpack all day
tomorrow okay okay so picture this
tomorrow which is so soon sitting on
your couch fire roaring in the
fireplace football on the TV chili in
the bowl Vibe
cultivated
I'm having a hard time seeing it because
I have like so much to do before that
Vision comes to peris but thank you at
least it's only like 36 hours worth of
doing you know it's not months you the
hard work is over you found the place
you're so close to the Finish Line why
are you giving up you're so close I'm
I'm giving up it's like you're one of
those people who like stumbles before
the end of the
marathon no no I'm like one of those
people in like a movie who like shits
the bed after doing all this work to
accomplish something for sure but if you
think of it like a marathon like you're
in the 25th mile you did 25 you have one
more mile left but like I don't want to
run another mile I already ran 25 walk
it okay whatever I'll figure it out
let's talk about other people's problems
not mine I would love to do that so
without further a do doo about tury tury
L here are the fast Ty stories that you
need to know and today's episode is
brought to you by State Farm the State
Farm personal price plan helps you
create a plan that gives you options so
you get an affordable price and it comes
with a lot of benefits like the coverage
you want a policy that helps cover
what's important to you and an
affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences so
think about it like this what are your
music playlist podcast feeds and social
media Scrolls all have in common well
spoiler alert they're a reflection of
you we all know my social media is full
of Travis Kelsey and Taylor Swift these
days Jackie's you know co-s sleeping
videos and how to properly latch for
breastfeed videos and that's because
soal everything is so personal in life
just like Jax and I that's what the
state F personal price plan is all about
it gives you options to help you
personalize your coverage that you can
protect what you care about most at an
affordable price just for you so you end
up seeing more of yourself in everything
you love and what's more important than
seeing yourself
nothing like a good neighbor St Farm is
there like a good neighbor they'll
report when you're
screaming like a good
neighbor let's
harmonize report State Farm is there oh
okay State Farm is sorry I was five like
six seven eight like a good neighbor f
is we'll say call or go to statefarm.com
today to create your State Farm personal
price plan prices vary by state options
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary call or go to
statefarm.com today today's episode is
also brought to you by game time you
shouldn't have to worry when you're
buying tickets to your next big event
game time is the fast and easy way to
buy tickets for all the sports music
comedy and Theater events near you with
killer last minute deals all in prices
views from your seat and their best
price guarantee game time takes a
guesswork out of buying tickets so game
time is the only ticketing app that
gives you complete peace of mind with
your purchase all in pricing shows your
total upfront so you know what you're
getting without hidden fees you can buy
tickets it's in seconds with two Taps
game time is deals on tickets right up
to the start of the event and even an
hour after after the event starts it's
the place to find last minute seats find
exclusive Flash Deals and sponsor deals
on tickets for football baseball
basketball concerts comedy theater and
more with Zone deals you pick the
section and Game Time picks the seats
for an average of 18% savings and the
game time guante means that you'll
always get the best price if you find
tickets in the same section in row for
Less game time will credit you 110% of
the difference so take the guesswork out
of buying tickets with Game Time
download the game time app create an
account and use code toast for $20 off
your first purchase terms apply again
create an account and redeem code t o a
s for $20 off download game time today
last minute tickets lowest price guad
oned always great to just have this app
on your phone if you travel or you live
in a fabulous City where fabulous things
are always going on keep it on your
phone I like that they show you the
pricing all up front not like other
websites when you buy a ticket for $5
and by the time you get to the end it's
$35 like it's insane thank you game time
for sponsoring today's episode today's
episode is also brought to you by eboost
if you're looking for an energy drink
that is healthy as well as tastes good
we have found it for you it helps you
feel more alert ready to accomplish
things on your to-do list and it is
eboost a non-GMO soyf free vegetarian
and glutenfree alternative with no
artificial flavors colors or sweeteners
and 15 calories or less per can eboost
is that girl who's that girl it's eboost
there's only 1 to two gram of sugar per
can and it's made of high quality
ingredients so it's perfect for everyday
energy late nights working late studying
before or after your workouts if you
travel a lot you get jet lag or you're
taking red eyes and just the common 3
p.m. slump for me it's more like a a
1:30 slump cuz I work early in the
mornings um but that afternoon slump and
crash can be brutal and ebo is here to
help also it's great if you had one too
many the night prior and you just need
something to whip you back into shape
the next day superfuel is fabulous
because it's low in sugar it's only 10
calories per can and it's formulated
with vitamins minerals anti antioxidants
neut Tropics so it's not what You'
normally expect from an energy drink so
when you compare it to all the other
popular energy drinks that has way less
sugar way less calories way more
vitamins it's made with natural caffeine
and no artificial sweetener so check out
eboost and we have a
gorgeous uh offer for you EB boost is so
confident that you're going to love
super fuel that they are giving you a
four pack for free all you have to do is
pay for shipping take advantage of this
offer today and go to ebbo boost.com
toast that's EB st.com / toast to get a
free four pack of superfuel super fuel
superfuel is available at EB boost.com
toast thank you Claudia you're welcome
our first story Little fashion news
Kylie Jenner announces her new clothing
line Kai here's everything we know so
far so Kylie posted on Instagram
yesterday um a new brand at Kai k y
there's two photos one of her in like a
black leather trench coat and then
another and kind of a black leather
trench coat but on the FL were they not
the same coat I don't know I don't think
so I thought maybe she was selling us
the
coat they're similar I'm not convinced
they're the same but they could be they
could be she has this one coat so in the
post she's posing in a long leather
trench a pair of bright bright red pumps
now via trademark um website I read the
trademark last night it's merchandise
apparel it's a clothing line so that is
established It also says like bath robes
right but I think you just register in
every category it said credit card
holders like I don't think she's
starting a credit card holding company I
have like an incredibly hot take
okay why why Kai why Kai
Kai I agree why she has so many
businesses that are but but here's the
thing she like doesn't really I feel
like whatever happened to Kylie swim
Kylie swim is done so she has Kylie skin
does she still yes which is like in my
opinion like a part of Kylie Cosmetics
Kylie Cosmetics like hasn't reformulated
they're working on like a few new things
I feel like they reformulated but like
no I'm saying all like they have the new
lip I have it here you left it here like
they have a few new things but like
everything else is like stuck in
2018 I I don't know why she's like not
working on
that I mean like another company they
just came out with their new concealer
that feel she could be doing more I feel
like she could be I feel like she could
be doing less which would wind up be
doing more like focus on the few core
businesses um and I do agree with that
cuz I feel like between Kylie skin Kylie
Cosmetics Kylie baby like there is Kylie
baby still around last I checked yeah if
you have to ask you know yeah but it's
not like you're like you wouldn't be
buying it so like I feel with for Kylie
a similar way with Kim like you have a
trademark Cornerstone of your brand Kim
has skim
Kylie is Kylie Cosmetics like why isn't
that enough why you have to go for skin
Kylie skin Kylie baby Kylie swim Kai why
why kai no I I hear you though I am
curious to see what this clothing line
is don't forget they also had Kendall
and kyy that actually was good [__] I
just want to say they sold it like paon
and [__] and Nordstrom and it was good
it was good I'm I just want to see what
she's going to be making like what the
price Point's going to be where it's
going to be sold I'm very open to this I
agree it's not necessary but it's not
the worst idea I've heard like Kylie
swim yeah okay let's do like a current
state of the union with all the
Kardashian Brands I feel like there's so
many I literally forgot up until this
very moment about Kylie baby like until
you said it I completely forgot about it
yeah and don't forget also those like
merch site like she used to have um
Kylie shop that was like clothes that
said Kylie yeah yeah King Kylie I I
bought a lot of it so Kylie has of
course Kylie Cosmetics she had Kylie
swim Kylie baby Kylie skin mhm is Kylie
skin still Yes okay is it a part of
Kylie Cosmetics let me go to Kylie
cosmetics.com I was actually just well
cuz I was just on Kylie Cosmetics
because I love I'm pretty sure it's
kylies skin.com no but it's like if I go
to Kylie Cosmetics can I shop skin it's
under the same yes yes you can yes skin
baby discover and baby yeah okay okay
great that's a nice site well makes more
sense
yeah and then Kim what the hell happened
to kkw
Beauty where has one person in the last
year bought
skin no what I
know I used mine still I used mine too
by the way because you paid for it so
like I I repurchase it GI it was a gift
um and I feel like kkw beauty is one of
Kim's like most cult cultish Brands like
people die for the lip liners like
people on Tik Tok are always talking
about how she needs to bring them back
the brand itself is just G kkw
fragrances right the fragrances Crystal
gardinia
yeah
kimoji okay that was a flop and Kim can
admit that I think we all know that was
Steph shef's fault right that's like why
she got fired I think because I saw she
was just on a podcast oh I didn't know
that t but she didn't say kamoji I just
feel like that was like Steph's idea and
it was a bad idea so you like fire the
person whose idea it was right I guess
so Kimo G was really bad that was like a
low point for Kim and we're like oh
she's never going to create a billion
dollar brand and then boom skims so it's
like why and I actually like what Kim's
doing she's really just focusing on
skims don't forget about Skai
Ventures okay that's different that's
not a business where you sell products
to people that's like a eventually I
think that eventually it will be because
I think they're I don't know that
they've made any Investments yet but
once they do it'll be like brands that
then they promote for sure for sure but
this is different I'm talking about I'm
talking about like full ownership of a
direct to Consumer company okay and Kim
is definitely scaled
back yeah I feel like all of her B
businesses
besides skims are pretty much like gone
except for skin I do think skin is still
it's stilling business MH it is but I
don't know for how much longer yeah then
Courtney and Khloe like got it down one
business move on good American and one
business under God individual that's two
but Po and ly they compliment each other
agreed agreed like no it's so funny how
we like clowned on Courtney for many
years for like not having a passion and
like she's a really kill I feel like ly
kills it yes she has a passion for sure
she has a passion for fashion yeah um we
have
safely safe flight repair safe flight
replace we do have safely Chris Jenner
how does that do too I good I get the pr
it's nice stuff me too you also cannot
forget about Arthur George no I I was
not going to but you know what we are
about to forget about wait let me think
818 yeah that's that's also like
a top five brand for the girls success
yeah yeah yeah but I just I I was
forgetting I kind of just forgot about
Kendall in general not you know yeah um
interesting I I I'm curious to see what
it is I feel like every time she
launches a product I get like so hyped
about it and I buy it and then it's just
like there's no not a lot of longevity
with some of her Brands yeah but that's
why I feel like this clothing line is
going to
be legit I do I don't think it's be high
fashion not so high I think midlevel I
don't think it's going to be crap
they've also like never done their own
clothing brand like Kendall and Kylie
was like a licensing deal with like I
think they Marcus or something yeah I
think I'm just very interested to see
what it's going to be and I'm very
hopeful and open to purchasing some of
it cuz I love Kylie
style yeah I don't know I also saw
people on Tik Tok saying it's a jewelry
company
oh why would it those pictures be a
jewelry company I don't know is she even
wearing jewelry in there like
no so girl boss Town who makes p
predictions like had a flop yesterday
where she guessed she didn't look up the
trademark like other people do she just
guessed based on the creative and like
what Kylie's been up to in the last
couple of years and she thought it would
be like a hair care company like hair
growth maybe serums because Kylie's you
know postpartum she talked about natural
hair um and while she ended up being
wrong and she said like okay sorry I
could have just Googled the trademark I
actually found it interesting that none
of the girls have done hair they used to
do Kardashian hair Kardashian hair but
that was like a Sear's thing I'm talking
about like their own Brands cuz there's
so much overlap between Kylie skin skin
kkw Beauty like there is a lot of
overlap so the fact that nobody just
went rogue and did hair yeah but I also
feel like hair they could do it without
it being this whole production like put
it under the Kylie skin umbrella like
it's it's just Beauty and she should
Rebrand them to like just Kylie Beauty
and it would be like Cosmetics skin hair
everything baby yeah yeah the
everchanging landscape of the Kardashian
direct to Consumer Brands is one of my
favorite topics and I hope to continue
reporting on it in the future me and as
well and I like being you know getting
premium
um what's the word products like I'm
open I'm first I'm open for business
having a conversation like a year ago
that Beyonce was starting a hair care
company remember yeah that was like two
months ago but yeah no that was not two
months ago it wasn't a year ago let me
tell you it was a year there's literally
no way no I think it was like when I was
in New
York no Jackie no
way Beyonce Hair Care brand May
16th when I was in New York was that uh
five months you're a
liar you're a liar you dirty little liar
but yeah we're still waiting for that
what's it from your Housewives no you
dirty little
liar me girls when Jenice in pops out of
the sunroof and catches Katie having a
party when she said she was going to see
L SM with black mambasa with her parents
yeah you dirty little liar that was like
a good impression
yeah well I look forward to hearing more
about kahai we'll keep you posted I do
like the name yeah I wonder what the H
is for probably just to make it cuz
everyone calls her Kai and that's KY but
that's like ugly two letters is not good
the H elevates it Kai yeah Kai
oh hi
[Laughter]
K that's why are you ready for our next
R which is some more fashion news my are
we fashionistas no we're Max anas we're
fashionistas for sure Dame Maggie Smith
proves to be the ultimate Fashion Icon
as she sends fans wild with a new L
campaign a queen with good taste to boot
so day Maggie Smith has been named as
the new face of the luxury Spanish
fashion house L the veteran of State
screen 88 years old delighted fans as
she posed for a series of striking
photographs while modeling the brand in
one image the star wowed in a ruffled
white dress layered over a black polo
neck jumper and a burgundy handbag the
photos are gorgeous our girl is a queen
quite literally she's actually a Dame uh
obsessed literally this like my l stock
goes up in not you know the stock market
but in my opinion I love this I take a
look at the photo do you think D Maggie
Smith is wearing a stitch of
makeup no isn't that interesting yeah
but what do you think of that that this
is how she wants to be I'm sure she had
pretty much control over the way she was
going to look like you can't really tell
the Dame what to
do and I think she looks
lovely I'm obsessed when you think of
day Maggie what role do you think of
almost immediately I think of Downtown
Abby me too I would say most people
think of Harry Potter I would say that
too but that's just the kind of gal she
is everybody has seen something with
Maggie Smith in it yeah she's someone to
everyone she's someone to everyone I
love that thanks also this really makes
me like L um let's talk about Lou for a
second yeah they're like the hot news
[__] on the street and also why isn't it
low oh don't get me come from the first
time it's l e we and you know my ass was
calling it LO like until somebody cored
me they're like it's l well that's and
so to use a w as a v that's
German like in Germany if someone's name
as Wilma in America they're Vilma like
the WV pipeline connection
Volkswagen that's Germany you just said
it's a Spanish brand in Spanish they
have other things with letters you know
two L's is y not L yeah the V is a v in
Spanish no I want to know where the V
comes from when there's no V in sight no
I want to know where the audacity comes
from to disregard phonetics and
Linguistics and I also just like want to
know where this brand came from out of
nowhere out of nowhere it came and it is
like everywhere everyone's wearing it
it's giving a like I I feel two ways but
it is giving industry plant a little bit
like it just popped up one day and
everyone decided it was going to be cool
I will say though that their stuff is
nice so it's not just like ugly things
that people are saying are cool yeah
they've got some nice things going on
but it's also relatively basic
simple yeah no and when new brands
happen I feel like it's such a slow roll
out to get to a place where you're
considered like a like a a designer
brand and and everybody knows your name
like I feel like a good brand that's
having that experience right now is Kate
k h AI t e and I've been hearing about
them like slowly for a while and Fashion
Week and when Morgan Stewart wears it
like you know it's good and then Ariel
chis like it's a very slow reil out but
it's like we all woke up one day and we
all knew what Lev was and how to
pronounce it yeah it's like the measure
it just showed up on our door shy it's
like the
measure yes I'm so glad you brought that
up no I'm telling you there's something
sus about it and now it's like it's so
big that it's like oh should I get a
fendy bag or Lou bag like it's not like
I feel like Kate it's like its own
category it's just clothes very I think
of it as like the row yeah but like when
if I were going to get like a designer
bag like all of a sudden like L is up
there with the ones that have been
around for decades totally and speaking
of designers I saw the craziest video
this morning on Tik Tok I see them all
the time with like um people in New York
like if you're waiting outside of a club
and you can't get in you know people
like start having breakdowns like do you
know who my father is and you they
always get filmed and they always get
put on the internet but the one that I
saw was like do you know who my father
is is the rich man in the world and
people figured it out his dad is the
richest man in the world the lvmh family
okay and his name was Alexander Arnold
and the dad is Bernard Arnold and he's
like having a [__] mental breakdown
outside of the club literally like so
you know who my father is he said it
like on a deling and he was like I will
buy this club I will buy this club and
the guy and the door man who's heard
this like from everyone in New York he's
like yeah sure and he was like the guy
was like do you know who my father is
and he's like oh you don't know who your
father is your daddy didn't tell you
like he's literally going back and forth
and every [__] in New York always
like if you've if you've been outside a
club you've seen someone having a
[__] me like full mental breakdown
for not getting into a club and being
like I'm going to call my uncle like but
this guy actually was someone yeah and
my God how humiliating you have to send
that to me that's hysterical oh I will
you know what I absolutely have to find
it I I just I have to find out the right
spelling of his last name and find it
people in the comments were so quick to
do the work because the video just got
posted nobody knew who he was but then
everybody's like that's Alexander Arnold
that's humiliating H Jackie and he was
so drunk and I want to say they're
Austrian I don't know what the accent
was giving do you know who my father is
I'll Google his
um nationality Arnold
German he's French oh okay wrong accent
zo you know who my father is yeah that
was actually that was more because it
was like less aggressive like I will buy
this club I will buy this
club no it was so funny honestly I think
I'm doing it funnier than it actually
was maybe don't send it to me so it can
live this way in my head I'm also
curious like what club it was based on
my like the small corner I want to say
it was Paul's Casablanca but I'm not
sure and I also want to know if he
bought the club yeah New Management no
when I tell you I ran to the comments
like just to see what people did people
on Tik Tok did all the work for me you
know yeah yeah spell their last name a r
n a u l
t
okay I had like just woken up I wasn't
like present enough oh so it's like
Bernard Arnold Bernard
Arnold wait say it again Bernard
Arnold
Bernard
what like the a RN like it's a s it's
just like if your last name's Arnold I
wouldn't have named my kid
Bernard of course I can't find the video
anymore Alexandre oh it's not dur
Alexandre I'll have to spend some
Alexandre Arnold hold on here he is
let's see if it's made the news
yet maybe it wasn't a new video maybe it
was just my first time seeing
it oh he cozied up to galgadot at
Tiffany inco event oh my God what isn't
she M I love finding out about like new
um famous wealthy people to like be
invested in cuz then I watched a video
on his dad and it was just saying how
like the dad um is very proud of his
family Legacy and they have like all all
the kids and the relatives they all like
are people of note you know so this was
like a huge Scandal for the family well
he's the Mastermind behind Tiffany and
CO's New Direction according to Vogue
he's like who is Alexander the no way
the guy I saw in that video the clubgoer
he's
31 that sounds right his name is
Alexandre he's the former CEO of
ramoa what wait bro thinks he's a movie
hold on oh and I have tiktok on my iPad
I think I might have found oh no I'm not
logged
in okay I need to find it like I'm so
annoyed yeah we'll okay we'll talk
offline yeah we'll talk offline okay are
you ready for our next story we need to
keep it moving cuz tury has to move and
what um it's number three don't get your
PR I'm ready I'm ready um Mauricio
yansky was spotted holding hands with
his Dancing with the Stars partner Emma
Slater amid Kyle Richard split so
romance rumors are heating up for
Mauricio and his Dancing with the Stars
partner Emma Slater amid his separation
from Kyle Richards Mauricio 53 and the
dance Pro 34 were spotted getting flirty
during terrible no no no I just wanted
to know their ages but these are
consenting adults yeah like if you're
over 30 like live your life yeah your
frontal lobe completed make your choices
yep uh Mauricio and the dance Pro were
spotted getting flirty during a romantic
dinner date at matsuhisa in Beverly
Hills California photos obtained by Page
Six Show The Duo holding hands as they
exited the restaurant and a witness said
that they exchanged kisses while seated
at the bar
inside I mean this isn't like surprising
but I do feel like so much of the Kyle
and
Mauricio divorce drama has kind of been
like spoiled like they've been trying to
like hold out for the show it's just
left people confused and like a little
annoyed and
now this is a confirmation right like
cuz this is an affair well I it's not an
affair I do think he's having like a
fling but I do think just in the way
that I see it I feel like him and Kyle
are kind of on a break like she's doing
living her life he's now meeting someone
else I feel like they might still get
back together cuz they're not like
officially divorcing but they're both
like seeing what else is out there right
now I don't know why that's how I see it
that's just the vibe I'm getting based
on everything they're putting out that's
totally fair because like even yesterday
he posted like a long tribute to Kyle
it's very clear that these are people on
good terms Kyle went to support and went
to a taping of Dancing With the Stars so
I think the idea of them being on a
break is entirely possible yeah just
like figuring out what the next chapter
is going to be and deciding if they
still want to be married but I don't
think the decision was made yet but then
this is also how things get messy what
if he like Falls for someone else what
if she was ready to come back to the
marriage or vice versa I don't know how
long this phase can last if if it's even
out as I see it which I like I said it's
just a feeling it's just a feeling but I
think you're right and also I think this
is cute like she's an age appropriate
girlly Emma you get very close it's very
hard not to fall in love with your dance
partner because it's so much time
together it's high stakes high energy
closeness physic physical Clos a lot of
trust has to be put into your partner
you're also sharing a lot cuz every
episode is like oh when I was six you
know you're opening up slowly week after
week you know opening a vein for
whatever the theme of the episode is
yeah and it's hard not to fall in love
think about how many like relationships
babies Robert herc Robert herc Nikki
Bella he's the gold standard oh so is
she yeah yeah there's a lot and people
are because I know this from Tik Tac
people are obsessed with Harry jowy and
his partner Riley and I need everyone to
stop because she's literally
18 let me go look Riley Arnold they are
like shipping her and Harry and they're
being so cute and they he's not that old
I think he's 30 you think and 18 is
really
young okay she's 18 he's
26 okay not horrible not horrible as far
as Hollywood goes okay they're so cute
sorry to like one of those people but um
she's really cute she's all over my Tik
Tok these days cuz her and Harry did a
dance on Dancing With the Stars that
went viral so you grab girls and you
grab a couple more and you all come meet
me at the middle of the floor and then
you spin and then Julian Huff did it
spin right um I'm obsessed I hope they
win and live happily ever after and get
married yeah I feel like they could win
thanks for bringing that to my attention
you're welcome I feel like I'm like to
attention today that you enjoy that I do
enjoy Alexandria Aral yeah I need to
find that
video um okay let's get into our next
story do you want to get into our next
story that's brought to you by L'Oreal I
do this episode of the toast is brought
to you by the new L'Oreal Paris bright
reveal dark spot serum and the
broadspectrum spf50 daily lotion dark
spots game over you know dark spots are
the main of my existence and I feel like
as I get older they get worse and I'm so
good with like my sun coverage but
sometimes the dark spot is a dark dark
spot especially after the summer so once
I was play when I was playing pickle
ball so much over the summer and just
like spending time outside with my gals
and and guy friends because I have a lot
of friends
um that's that's what someone who has a
lot of friends says yeah yeah dark spots
became a really big issue for me and
just because Summer was over does not
mean you need to stop wearing your SPF
SPF is also everyday so we are
protecting our skin we are helping our
dark spots with Loreal Paris so the
bright revealed 12% dark spot serum
visibly Fades all types of dark spots
such as age spots sunspots as well as
post- acne marks so it visibly Fades up
Fades all types of dark spots up to 40%
in one week they start fading even the
most stubborn dark spots after two weeks
your skin looks clearer skin texture
looks refined and smooth there's also
the bright reveal spf50 daily UV lotion
we got to like in our old age ladies we
have to be wearing sunblock like all the
time even if you're not you know tanning
if you're outside you need to protect
your skin I love the one from L'Oreal
Paris and when paired with the dark spot
Duo this Derm validated Duo visibly
reduces the look of dark spots in just
one week visibly Fades and protects from
dark spots so discover the new bright
revealed darkspot Duo visit Target
online and in store to buy yours today
today's episode is also brought to you
by the inky list skincare can be
confusing and with all the complicated
Beauty jargon it can seem nearly
impossible to figure out what is
actually best for your skin well now you
don't need to figure it out on your own
cuz you can shop with confidence at the
inky list the inky list is an
award-winning science back SK care brand
that has the right ingredients at an
affordable price to get the results
you're looking for whether it's
targeting acne reducing Fine Lines
boosting hydration the inky list creates
a unique skincare routine that really
works so you can reach your skin goals
if you don't know where to start your
first stop should be their online
skincare quiz they'll answer all your
questions so you can make better
decisions about your skin like do I
really need a toner and what's actually
polyglutamic acid or is skipping
moisturizer making my oily skin worse
also the inky list just launched a new
product that will take your routine to
the next level with their new Plumping
lip balm you can get up to 40% plumper
lips in just four weeks without filler
without a filter they're just Fuller
check out the before and afters on their
website if you don't believe me also
available at Sephora so right now the
inky list is offering our listeners 20%
off their purchase with promo code toast
go to the inky list.com that's spelled i
n ke y so the inky i n ke y list.com
promo code toast for 20% off your order
that's the iny list.com promo toast for
all of your skincare needs thank you
Inky list for sponsoring today's episode
thank you you're welcome our next story
a little more fashion news Haley Bieber
is on the cover of GQ and she's talking
about why she and her husband Justin
dress like they're on two separate
planets she did a good interview there
was a lot of little sound bites from and
she looked [__] gorgeous yeah she
said um she got real about everything
from her skincare line to her life in
the spotlight with her husband Justin in
the new interview with GQ hyp published
on Tuesday including why she and her
spouse off step out in completely
mismatched outfits she said it's so
funny because I see so many people talk
about this um it looks like often looks
like they're attending events on two
separate planets yeah she said the
reason for this is because he typically
Gets Ready first which could partially
explain why she doesn't dress to match
his super casual fits she also told GQ
that he might want to wear baggy sweats
to dinner and I might want to wear a
tiny little dress because that's just
how I'm feeling we can't sit there and
be like so I'm going to wear this and
you're going to wear this like this is a
funny thing but the fact that it needs
to be explained like is everybody dumb
like he's a man and he wants to be
comfortable and he doesn't give a [__]
what he looks like cuz he's rich and
famous and she's a gorgeous Glam Amazon
who wants to be fabulous and she gets
dressed up because it's fun and she's a
trendsetter like need we explain more
yeah but it's just a funny thing to then
behold I also saw I don't know if it was
from this interview but she was talking
about how you know when the day comes
when they start a family like the
internet will be the last people to know
yes talking about like pregnancy rumor
swirling she was saying like I can't
even be bloated one time and not be
pregnant she said that it hurts her
feelings it's disheartening yeah no I
actually read some comments yesterday
where people thought I was pregnant
they're like Claud is dropping Easter
eggs I was like being a little weird at
the end of the episode but I wasn't like
like literally no no no I'm still on o
epic like you can't get pregnant so yeah
yeah I saw that um I saw that too I like
to create drama yeah and you like to
create mystery and Intrigue around
yourself yeah no and if people like
think I'm pregnant like okay think about
me some more and it's not like a bad
thing being pregnant's beautiful like oh
you think I'm beautiful thanks
yeah but
um I just love haly bber I know same and
now it's like that's their that's their
couple style is one of them to be like
so dressed down her to be so dressed up
I love those memes that it's like me and
my toddler and like like she's the
toddler who's like dresses she's a meme
people dresses her for Halloween already
they're going to I'm sure like when she
at the Crispy Cream event where she wear
that red outfit the red outfit and he's
in a grit yeah that's a Halloween
costume so you know what it's fun it's
flirty it's fresh say what you want
about these two they're hot and heavy go
and strong jelina can eat my ass yeah
and I also feel like for a lot of
couples like this is how they dress like
the men just want to be comfortable
they're not getting all doled up with
you but like I'm a fashion girly and I'm
going to wear my l oh no I ended up on
jelina talk again like these people who
think Selena and Justin should be
together and they used AI oh to make
like updated photos of Selena and Justin
like in love and like married I think
there was also one with like a baby it
was really sick it was sick that's
really crazy AI is dangerous Jackie they
look they were right AI can be dangerous
in the wrong hands in the hands of a
gelina
stand Jackie it looked so real send it
to me I know I hate to send you Tik toks
because I know you can't like open them
um I can open them and I watch them but
sometimes it depends what it what the
cover photo is because sometimes I'm
like I don't want to watch this ugly
person and I feel like I do send you Tik
toks and you don't respond no like you
sent me one the other day and I'll tell
you why I didn't even open it it was
just looked like an ugly person like
talking about something and I just
wasn't God we're all beautiful Jackie we
are all beautiful no here wait no I'm
scrolling no I watch I watched Novak
jokovic oh yeah I say you something of
Novak jokovic um if I didn't respond
just know that I did see it
oh wait I have to go look that one I'm
not going to share but I didn't look at
it but the caption made me laugh and I
could imagine what it
was oh okay I guess I do really look at
most of what you send me oh you know
let's go to Links in our chat history I
also should not have opened my phone
because Ben going to need new rugs
they're not going to fit in this
space Oh goodness that's not the energy
we need right now Ben
no but I'm going to hit up uh rug you
have any ruges I don't have ruges
they're machine
washable I know and they have the little
like things it's actually great for kids
I would love some rug bus but I also
just got some nice rugs from rugs USA
they are toasters over there if you need
a rug they're also toasters at ruggable
so well I I mean you can never have
enough rugs no it's so true especially
like it's I actually wanted to get rid
of one of my rugs like when you have a
dog like you can't really like keep rugs
like Theo was trained
on this rug yeah on this here rug yeah I
would like rugs from rug B and rug USA
this is not a sponsor we're just like
for rugs [__] for free things yeah
we're just whoring ourselves out don't
mind us yeah don't move along nothing to
see here unless you work for a rug or
furniture brand or Furniture Company
yeah you can skip ahead you can shoot me
an email any other Furniture needs that
you have you know what I really need and
I'm I need everything I really need
outdoor furniture and I know what oh me
too me too I have outdoor space Oh okay
outdoor furniture brands um that we
don't like already work with if anyone
like wants to send some stuff yeah
anything else you need we should have a
section on the show because again it's
our show it's we're the bosses where we
just like tell the universe what we need
and see if any like social media
managers want to work together oh my God
okay I need like everything for a new
home like I probably need a whole new
set of um pots and pans because mine
were so old I'm going to get from
caroway okay um caroway came out with a
few new gorgeous pieces that I need to
get my hands on so anything home decor
related like I need a bed for my guest
room I need rugs I just need like a lot
of stuff from a Furniture website yeah
any and all furniture websites are
beautiful and I'm sure to find something
I love for many of them and I'm happy to
leverage my enormous following you know
yeah for some free
stuff yeah okay that's all I also ended
up on this other side of Tik Tok I
actually think you'll be interested like
talking about the business of
influencing
um and this debate of like whether or
not being an influencer is a hard
job what were they saying so PE and it's
from creators themselves like people
with you know big Tik Tok followings or
people who have followings but also work
regular Jobs still and the general
consensus was like no it's not a [__]
hard job like there is hard work
involved but it's really not physically
laborious it's not manual labor um and
it's a lucky you're it's a job you're
lucky to have then there was a whole
other conversation about how you know
other jobs that are much more arduous
and physical and taxing um don't have
the mental
health consequences consequences that
influencing does and they you know
people said that's also a good point
yeah no influencing like the the work
itself whether you're like you know
filming a video or real if you're good
at it it's not incredibly hard but it's
still takes time and whatever but there
is a component of being an influencer
that is very difficult in your daily
life and it never turns off it's not
like 5 o' I'm going to shut my computer
you have like the like there is in terms
of actual work as in tasks it is not a
difficult job no but are a lot of jobs
like any AD like administrative computer
laptop job a laptop job
yeah you know the ones we used to have
laptop jobs yeah of course of course um
but I just thought it was an interesting
combo it is an interesting combo I would
say the difficulty lies in having
everyone's opinion of you like be a part
of your work and not something that you
can ignore turn off ever yeah and like
being forced to receive just like that
mass amount of opinion
yeah you've got to have a strong
Constitution like the girls at done and
done it always comes back to the strong
Constitution are you ready for our fifth
and final story I am and I just want to
say I'm feeling so much better the Chast
is so restorative and healing I knew it
would be you just have to trust the
process just the
process our fifth and final story Erica
Jane reveals why she's still married to
Tom gerardi she said I just had no idea
I had no idea I hadn't thought about it
but now that I think about it yet we
never got like finalized past that you
know election day divorce what happened
next Ed D election day divorce yeah that
was crazy that was crazy so we're coming
up on three years now of when they filed
it was it was presidential election it
was election yeah so next year if
anybody wants to bury their divorce in
the News election day divorce you have
about a year to prepare G your ducks in
order yeah Erica Jane is not concerned
about finalizing her divorce from her AR
strange husband Tom gerardi she said
quote in an interview with Entertainment
Tonight which just is the best
interviews with the best people AG great
she said in the order of all of the
problems I'm facing it's probably the
absolute last thing I care about I just
don't think about it the day I filed for
divorce and we were legally separated
that was it for me we are in very
different places I have a lot to clean
up and pick up and move on she added
that the timing of everything all comes
down to needing to protect herself she
said even after a two decade plus
marriage that's what it came down to
looking out for
yourself I had idea these two were still
married I guess I I do imagine she's not
dying to get married again so legally
being married means nothing mhm um I
don't think Tom's really in a position
to like bother her about this like you
know and no I know this is going to be
like so mean I feel like she's probably
just like waiting for him to die yes
he's in a facility he's very old so it
probably would just be easier that way
if she becomes a widow
instead yeah and it's not like them
being technically married I I don't
think he's you know bang down her door
or anything it's the same difference
it's just less paperwork to stay married
but separated than to go through the
process and I'm sure also trying to
divorce someone who's mentally unwell in
a conservative trip like more paperwork
it's just a lot as she said she's got a
lot on her plate I I understand this
yeah I actually think this is going to
be an amazing season of be Beverly Hills
housewives I feel starts so long today
tomorrow does it yeah it's like it was
supposed yeah it's this week it might
even be tonight oh F my God I won't have
my TVs installed it might be tomorrow
I'll let me look it up for you that's
fabulous I feel like we're we're going
to have a really good season between
Kyle stuff new housewife they took a
little bit of a break so it's just been
a long time so our first season without
Rena but I'm really not worried no I'm
not worried either um like I was just
watching when I was in LA cuz I was just
watching Bravo on the TV and they were
airing that season of Beverly Hills
where Denise gets you know it's tonight
tonight where Denise they go to Rome and
Lisa Rena turns on Denise you're so
angry and it was just so good yeah I
really miss that franchise it's been a
very long time yeah and we haven't been
watching housewise right now but that's
the perfect franchise to get us back
into it on it now that I know actually
I've been watching I've been watching
New York and solic city oh true well for
me I'll be back in and it might make me
want to watch all the other ones I have
recorded I need to catch up on the new
roony reunion I heard it was actually
very good
yeah um and I'm going to Bravo con which
I'm really excited about go turty go
turty go turty go go turty go turty go
was that the fifth and final story that
was that's it okay good good yeah Ben
sent me some turn pictures of my big new
furniture in my apartment it's like not
going to fit well you do have to take
out some modules from your couch we knew
that
yeah but now texting me are you done
recording cuz I have a potentially bad
idea call you in we love the self-a
awareness oh my God Ben is I need to get
over there because he wants to make one
of the bedrooms a dining room okay I
have to go I have to go save my family
now you know why we can't have dear
toasters today yeah thank you guys so
much for listening to the toast Monday
Morning Show where we deal with the fast
stories every M Friday and new are
watching us on YouTube please for to
subscribe oh my bedroom looks so good
send me a picture send it to me right
now
okay hold on like I have Windows and
Views and sky and
buildings I think I need a bigger carpet
but I'll I'll survive thank you guys so
much for listening to the to
show I literally knew you were going to
say that thank you guys so much for
listening to the to Monday morning show
we Del the fast five stories you need to
know every Monday Friday on YouTube so
if you're watching us on YouTube please
fre to subscribe and give us video a
thumbs up we're also available as
podcast anywhere podcast can be found on
Spotify iTunes s public radio radio cast
box all the places we you SE podcast
find us if I'm Sor you but a beautiful
setting and wickedly talented we are
jaie did you get the picture of my bed
it looks so good I got a picture it
looks so good you need a new rug but it
looks amazing need a new rug it's too
small right yeah you should also put
some wallpaper in there I did I bought
new wallpaper oh what kind the same one
for my old apartment but like new rolls
of it garie Pary do you not like that
wallpaper no I do okay I do I guess like
yeah if you're moving like I love my
bedroom wallpaper if I moved right you
take your wallpaper I would get it again
yeah yeah like I love it should I get a
new one no no no I love wallpaper me too
it's such a fabulous fun fresh way to
spice up especially a rental to class up
the place to class up the place okay I
really got to go okay love you love you
guys bye